all right welcome everybody we're gonna
skip the songs today it just does not
seem appropriate given this uh
horrifying horrifying school shooting
that has taken place today in uvalde
texas
where as of right now we believe 20
people have been killed it is another 18
year old shooter
uh information is still developing the
shooter apparently born in one of the
dakotas
and bought two firearms on his 18th
birthday
um and it's still early as you all know
i often don't cover shootings until
several days later because
often the information that is released
early is inaccurate or whatever the case
may be
but
but what i can tell you is that we are
seeing
dramatically more
weaponized disinformation being spread
including ideas like for example let me
see where i have this hold on
um
from texas attorney general ken paxton
who said well maybe the solution we need
to look at is arming the teachers and
think about that i even i actually
tweeted my thoughts on this the solution
to gun violence in schools is to give
those terrible irresponsible critical
race theory teaching indoctrinators who
they've been attacking for years
firearms with which to defend the
classrooms we're going to
give these horribly incompetent teachers
guns that doesn't really seem to make
sense by their own assessment right
let's listen to what ken paxton had to
say
uh here we go as as you well know the
state of texas not a stranger to
shootings that either begin in schools
or wander into schools
uh
i know your team has dealt with this
before what were some of the solutions
and i know that governor abbott
lieutenant governor patrick have also
come up with tasks for task forces to
harden these schools so they're not easy
targets easy prey for crazy people who
go nuts with firearms uh
what what can you tell us has been
talked about in the past what has been
implemented and what hasn't been
yeah sadly this has happened again and
it's it's a horrible tragedy but the
types of things that we talked about and
i'll never forget it after the santa fe
shooting it was having one point of
entry making it more difficult for
people even to get in that point of
entry make sure that they
and having potentially
teachers and other administrators who
have gone through training who are armed
because first responders
teachers and administrators who have
gone through training who we will arm in
the schools
i don't know guys but um
maybe we should at least consider some
gun safety regulations restrictions and
the re and the reduction of the number
of guns that are just floating around
out there now if you want to deal with
mental illness i'm fine dealing with
mental illness the republicans never
want to fund
making mental health treatment more
accessible
less expensive
encouraging people to seek treatment
they stigmatize
and they say we're not going to fund
that we're not going to fund this that's
communism that's socialism and on and on
and on
so i'm fine saying okay
let's consider that a lot of these
shooters are disturbed for lack of a
better term
but you look at the buffalo shooter's
manifesto
it's cogent and coherent fascism
okay and so
i don't even know that if evaluated that
guy would have would have necessarily
been like oh well for sure we got to
take the guns away we gotta make it
easier to take guns away
when people uh you know the red flag
flag laws as they're called but the idea
of it's simply a matter of mental
illness it's not it's not but
if you thought it was you should be
doing something to deal with and they
don't want to fund it which is just
incredible so it is election night okay
this is a complicated evening because it
is election night we're going to start
looking at election results momentarily
in addition
uh president biden is going to address
the nation on this shooting momentarily
believed to be about 15 minutes from now
and of course the um cnn is going to
cover it
but
i also i always want to have a backup
stream for you guys because i i just
respect the audience so much
so let's have that and we'll watch this
in terms of the early election results
let's take a look
wait this isn't it this isn't it
this isn't it
um
okay
so
a lot of these won't be updating until
now
early on the data with 16
in brian kemp is obliterating david
perdue now
understand this is a loss for trump if
these results hold if these results hold
um
this wasn't supposed to start till eight
pacific no no no it was scheduled for
eight eastern scheduled for eight
eastern so i don't know what you're
talking about um if these results hold
this is a loss for trump trump touts
this admittedly bo i admit admittedly
bogus endorsement record trump endorsed
purdue pence endorsed brian kemp now
pence's endorsement was also horse
manure pence swooped in at the last
second and said i endorse kemp kemp was
gonna win all along okay but um this is
this would be a loss for donald trump in
uh in our kansas no wait in uh well yeah
in our kansas i i presume trump endorsed
sarah huckabee sanders we don't have any
data yet in from there
i think she's expected to win easily and
in alabama
correct me if i'm wrong did scrumps
endorse mo brooks i know ted cruz
endorsed brooks but did trump endorse
brooks in in alabama can anyone in the
chat remind me
i just don't remember i think he did but
he rescinded the endorsement is that
true
trump moe brooks
endorsement let's see
um
march 23rd trump rescinds endorsement of
mo brooks oh my god well imagine if he
ends up winning now trump will say well
it was thanks to my temporary
endorsement it was thanks my temper
endorsement so we're watching all of
these results there's some stuff
happening in minnesota as well
although to be honest i'm not totally
sure about the significance of it
first district special election
in um texas there's a democratic runoff
but the big the thick meaty races today
in my opinion are the republican
oh my god
you got to be kidding me
okay
looks like some kind of audio test there
all right everybody just relax oh it's
happening again all right we're just
gonna mute it i don't need test tones
uh look at the pennsylvania senate
election oh yeah let's get those results
and see what's going on
um just finding these for us
oh wow
look at this guys thanks pappy for the
heads up they're still counting ballots
in the pennsylvania republican primary
it has now gotten even closer with 99
percent of the vote in
the gap between mehmet oz and dave
mccormick is down to just
under a thousand votes
so uh i believe that there will be an
automatic recount there anyway and now
they're arguing about whether or not to
count a mail-in ballots it's crazy now
it's it's not there's not even a
democrat running and they're still
arguing about which mail-in ballots to
count so it's uh it's pretty wild and
and weaponized stuff
um okay so we're trying to keep up with
all of it uh president joe biden is
going to speak momentarily momentarily
oh did i say something wrong about what
sarah huckabee is running for i thought
i said governor did i say senate
did i
misspeak running for governor not senate
if i said senate
okay maybe maybe people are just
informing me i don't know okay very good
so we're standing by for joe biden
worst mass shooting in a school since
sandy hook
uh lieutenant um uh the attorney general
of texas says we need to arm teachers
it's it's delusional it's absolutely
delusional what's taking place here um
and i it's it's just absolutely stunning
cnn has oz lead down to 901. okay yeah
that's roughly what we're seeing
um
where was that pennsylvania
here
i guess i should keep this over to the
side maybe i'll put it i'm just
organizing my tabs for everybody just
trying to keep an organized stream for
us today i want to say thank you to
holly grock liquid ice
cubeemus
nug wrangler for the twitch prime
subscriptions really appreciate it the
streams are sometimes back to back to
back at this point also thank you to
kevin gouldy who just signed up using
the coupon code obama obama and also
thanks to connor murphy who just signed
up on my website with that very same
coupon code it is going to be a very
busy night indeed we are watching
election results from arkansas alabama
and georgia plus a couple of elements
from minnesota and texas we're waiting
for joe biden any moment he's going to
address the nation on this horrific
shooting that has taken place in texas
guys i don't know how we stop this there
might be no way to stop the shootings i
mean
only this country has this problem
no other country has this problem
there's probably nothing we can do we've
also tried nothing
and we're all out of ideas so you be the
judge you be the judge
uh sickening
there's really no other way to put it
other than sickening what's going on
um
we don't know anything about motive yet
we just we just don't know
uh no manifesto that i'm aware of at
this point in time
but i mean listen we're following all of
it we're following all of it
um let me see what else i had some of
the stuff that doesn't seem
necessarily totally right for today
here is one of the dads of the parkland
shooting who understandably just lost it
today on msnbc
but for the next
bunch of days and weeks
you have to get through this
this horror because people failed
i i i'm done they [ __ ] failed our
kids again okay i'm done i've had it
you know this is on msnbc by the way how
many more times
are we and we're going to sit back i'm
going to listen to that governor of
texas
talk about why he
pushed to fight laws and for laws in
texas
that made it easier
for the guns to be had by those who want
to kill
how many more times
i i don't i mean i'm sorry i'm
speechless i don't know what to say
you know but you know what
tomorrow i'm going to wake up
we're going to keep fighting because as
long as there's people like you
and people like senator murphy
and
you know i look on the house
they're trying to pass things i look at
a president who will sign legislation
that makes it to his desk this was
predictable
but it was also preventable
sadly the next one that's going to
happen is also predictable if we keep
doing nothing
and so i am begging
senator cruz i sat with you in your
office two years or so ago
i listened to your nonsense i listened
to your bs i listened to you explain to
me why you thought we didn't need the
bare minimum of effective background
checks
march into senator murphy's office right
now tonight
and you
be the republican who says
i've had enough because that's not going
to be ted cruz unfortunately that is not
going to be the person who does it um
super chat here says remember that those
republican talking points about arming
teachers and needing more guns came
straight for the end from the nra yeah
um greg abbott listen to listen to this
okay
the republican governor of texas greg
greg abbott who wants more guns in more
places
maybe armed teachers certainly no
regulations or whatever he's scheduled
to speak at the nra convention this
weekend
that convention should be cancelled if
they had any shame whatsoever they would
cancel the convention by the way scrumps
is also
scheduled to speak
so
at the convention
they don't allow guns
i mean
guys
what what the hell is going on in this
country
okay
school shooting in texas
governor lieutenant governor attorney
general no no no no more guns no
regulations okay
greg abbott going to speak at the nra
convention
three days after this shooting
where they don't allow guns
obviously it would be unsafe to allow
guns in there and let all those lunatics
in there with these elected officials
it it's um
man
it's really something else i did tweet
let me see where this was
um
i i tweeted a little bit about the whole
mental illness thing it's just a like a
very short thread
um and i i this mostly summarizes my
view the mental illness element of gun
violence isn't an either or yes there is
often a mental illness component and we
should make mental health treatment
easier to access and affordable which
most republicans oppose they call it a
government takeover or socialist or
whatever
that being said most quote mentally ill
people which sometimes just means you
like have anxiety you know
most mentally ill people are not violent
and never commit any violent acts nor
crimes however for the small percentage
that does if there are fewer guns around
or they're more difficult to access
whatever violence they try to commit
will be less lethal right if your
argument is that today's shooter was
mentally ill
great okay let's fund mental health
treatment which they're opposed to
but if instead of what's the number
300 million guns or two if instead of
that number of guns around there's a
smaller number it's just mathematically
more difficult
for that mentally ill person to find a
gun so why wouldn't we be doing that
and lastly i said this is an issue of
number one
too much too easy access to guns two a
culture that celebrates or at least
plausibly is okay
with firearms as a way to solve
interpersonal or societal problems
that's unique to the united states for
the most part
and untreated and undiagnosed mental
illness as a result of the disastrous
health care system which by the way the
people saying this is merely a problem
of mental illness never actually want to
fund they never actually want to fund it
um
that's
i don't know i don't know what else to
say guys
um
okay
i want to say thanks to juan for gifting
a membership thanks juan yeah it's a
it's a crazy day here
um also want to say thanks to simon reed
for gifting a membership and i'll give
those away we yeah we
we're going to be doing this uh
for a while
robin mace you get a free membership and
dakota giles you get a free membership
super chats keep coming in
i don't know how you keep your cool
after this shooting it'd be incredibly
difficult for me keep up the good work
and thanks uh thanks dion
i want to know if marjorie marjorie
taylor green loses oh right
is that um hold on i didn't even see
that here
oh so by the way herschel walker has won
that's a trump endorsed guy he seems to
have suffered from he seems to have a
brain injury and very very serious
mental illness i'm not making fun of it
he seems completely unqualified in terms
of his ideology but he also seems to
have some real real real issues which
have been talked about before trump
endorsed him nobody talks about it the
guy won it's crazy raphael warnock won
didn't have a serious challenger
let me see where the
marjorie taylor green thing is
uh brad raffensburg oh this is another
loss for trump another loss for trump
trump if i recall correctly endorsed
jody heiss whose disgusting disgusting
person jody heiss you might remember of
course that brad raffensberger is the
guy trump asked for the votes i need 11
000 votes give me a break okay so that
was another kind of vendetta endorsement
for prompt he lost that one
and where is um
man where is marjorie taylor green it's
not on here is
is her primary not today or what i don't
even know i don't know i don't know
what's going on with marjorie taylor
green does anybody know like why isn't
does she even have a primary i'm not
even sure
i just don't i don't know what the hell
is going on quite frankly it should be
today yeah
but it's not showing up here
um
marjorie taylor green primary i i
apologize we're just trying to um
keep up with everything
georgia's 14th district oh it's on a
different page sorry guys sorry sorry
sorry okay so we need to go to the 14th
district here
14th
uh marjorie taylor green uh cry just
absolutely crushing okay so it's over
marjorie taylor green
in all in all likelihood
is going to face well i mean it's listen
it's still early they haven't called it
but it's probably over
it's probably over let's give it a
little bit of time okay
uh and we are standing by for
joe biden other super chats i'm
indigenous and i'll never vote unless
they do something worth to make my
people's lives better
i i respectfully disagree with this
perspective
if you never vote
you have no leverage
you have no leverage
the starting point should be i'm going
to vote
and i'm going to make demands
and i'm going to get involved i disagree
with this deeply imagine imagine if so
extend this to its logical conclusion
imagine if everyone who said i don't
feel represented now so i'm not going to
vote you will never be represented
because you're taking yourself out
you'll i mean it's it's a loser's game
that's that's absurd
it's it's sort of like when people say
um
i'm not gonna vote because it never
comes down to one vote
like it's never come down to one vote so
my vote could never be the difference
maker okay right but how many people
think that many people say to themselves
that
if 10 000 of them say it and stay home
now that contingent
is responsible for an election going a
different way
you it this is just the the bare minimum
okay
the bare minimum
disagree with it
just disagree with it
um
if you're just joining us it's an
extremely busy evening in american
politics
disastrous mass shooting at a school in
texas okay as of right now we believe
there have been 20 deaths that's 18
children
one adult
and the gunman 18 years old
bought two guns on his 18th birthday
look up henry kweller 28 in texas
okay let's see so if we look at texas
uh where is that one
caller
um
am i missing it
sheila jackson a lot of unopposed here
oh here it is um
he's getting
absolutely crushed
absolutely crushed so it looks like as
of right now it looks like incumbent
henry kweller is going to be removed
that's what it's looking like at this
point in time
uh
okay
all right uh i want to say thank you to
andrew avdrums for gifting a
subscription i really appreciate that
you're number nine i'm going to give
that subscription away to sandy barker i
also want to say thank you to colin
medhurst colin medhurst just signed up
at joinedpakman.com
and his new member number 10 and i'm not
ignoring everybody on twitch thanks to
massa's hero
but it's my hipaa who has also
subscribed
um
[Music]
those are numbers um
11 and 12. uh okay joe biden expected to
speak any moment any any moment we are
standing by
other super chats david sir what a sad
day for humanity my heart is shattered
and i'm so angry the only good news i
have is i voted in the primary well well
done well done
christopher says gun control seems
entirely off the table do you think
there's any possibility to very harsh
forms of retributive justice justice
for mass shooters
uh i don't know
i don't know i'd have to think about
that
i'm not exactly sure i know what you
mean necessarily
okay
um
but we have we have we have a sickness
here
in this country
let me see if oh by the way just like
this isn't super on topic but just kind
of related to to crappy people
this is video i guess it's of a woman
taking all the formula potentially to
resell it let me see what this is
someone sent this to him
look at this
look at all this
look at the shelves
you don't think i need it for my baby
too
you think i know you're coming you get
this one before
you just you just cleared the whole
shelves of all of this formula if you
saw me you check that because i'm
playing i'm praying for
and i'm not paying for it i don't i am a
child
and you just clearly
you just cleared the hole oh can you
share with me or something like that
because i saw in here i'm buying i don't
know you can't look at me i say oh i
want to check that because i'm waiting
patiently was i not waiting patiently i
don't know you get there but still this
is the whole reason why there's a
formula shortage you take all the
formula right the shelf and buy it all
at once right you come after me i don't
know you get this one it doesn't matter
i'm saying this is the whole reason why
there's a formula shortage
you come and you buy all the formula at
once right and there's kids who need
formula today who won't be able to get
it because i mean do we need to just put
a limit on the amount of formula you're
allowed to buy i don't know you just
want it to stock up
i mean there was one on toilet paper
early in the pandemic problem right
and off she goes yeah
pretty i mean there's there's just you
know there's pretty horrible people i
don't know what else to say it's just uh
how many problems how many different
problems do we have it's absolutely
insane
um
when is biden speaking he was scheduled
to speak five minutes ago i assume he
will speak any moment here's our friend
juliet kayam she follows me on twitter
uh she's very very nice let's listen to
what she has to say been reunified with
their children so they know who the
parents are uh but now each parent has
to identify a child that may be
unrecognizable and un without
identification and i think it's
important to to be direct about and
specific and detailed however horrifying
this moment is for these families
because that's what these families are
going through and we uh we'll we'll look
to the motive and we'll look to
obviously uh guns and and gun control uh
but uh we can't get sanitized to the
horror of what's happening right now
that's what the delay is is there's
children who are unrecognizable
but only a parent their parent can
identify them and um can you imagine you
know that's that's this moment right now
and
julia on a scene like this i mean and
yeah i know this only because we've
covered other school shootings as well
it's very likely these children are
still
where they fell and will be for some
time as this
crime scene
as it is now has to be documented and
gone over
right so we know from sandy look at me
the shooter is dead the shooter is dead
uh as based on every report that we have
received so far
and from the report from texas officials
as well
uh uh utter utterly insane
utterly insane
in terms of election results let's take
another scan through
we're starting to get some results if we
look at
alabama
we see that
we still have nothing from the senate
primary okay
if we look at arkansas we still have
nothing on sarah huckabee sanders
if we look at georgia we now have 17 of
the vote in now 21 of the vote in and
this is going to be a very very big loss
for donald trump
donald trump endorsed david perdue who's
absolutely horrifying
mike pence opportunistically at the last
moment endorsed brian kemp
who's also horrible by the way
uh but less horrible he at least wasn't
willing to like steal the election
uh openly
okay so we're watching that
marjorie taylor green with a very big
lead at 25 of the vote in her primary
the most likely outcome is that marcus
flowers will will win on the democratic
side and then marjorie taylor greene
will win on the republican side and that
will be the general election and
meanwhile they are still counting
ballots in the pennsylvania republican
primary this is from a week ago we were
all here a week ago
they are still counting ballots and the
lead is now under 900 votes
for memit oz a tenth of one percent
and the i don't know if they're still
counting ballots they seem to have a
very very limited ballot counting
schedule there in pennsylvania so i
don't know if those numbers are going to
change during the stream
but uh that we are going to monitor and
joe biden expected to speak any minute
so we'll we'll be here for the evening
um
following following all of this
uh thanks to gingerdale for the twitch
prime subscription i really do
appreciate everybody who's supporting us
today over on the website i want to say
thanks to nicholas miller who just
signed up
angelo carlin who's a new member
and nick fernandez who just signed up
those are new members 14 15 and 16 and
then a couple gifts to give away andrew
avdrums
and kay shockey have just gifted two
more memberships i have like 400 people
waiting for memberships i'll give away
two more don white gets a free
membership and gail cardoza if you want
a free membership just go to
davidpakman.com free membership okay
i'll there's no trick to it
um if you if you fill the form out twice
they're all deleted and you get nothing
okay
and we just go in order there's 433
people right now who are waiting and i
will i will just go in order there's no
trick to it there's no trick to it just
don't um
you know
okay oh and ginger dale it wasn't twitch
prime it was regular twitch
and 33 months thank you gingerdale
also towel c
has subscribed with prime i appreciate
that and you have not missed joe biden
speaking yet it was scheduled for 10
minutes ago
he has not yet spoken we are seeing
election results come in
and we are seeing um we are seeing a lot
of a lot of different things go on now
people are telling me that the
cisneros results
are uh deceptive
uh oh wait okay wow
well now it looks tight now it is not
clear at all now that henry kweller is
actually going to be removed
it is now
almost 50 50 with 68 of the voting
so it may ultimately come down to the
wire
it may come down to the wire we're going
to keep an eye on that we're keeping an
eye on everything okay all of this stuff
is breaking as we go i want to say
thanks to cody kulp who says david did
bobby piten ever send you all his
evidence he said he had on the 2020
election
he did not
it may come as a shock to you but bobby
piten who told me hey tomorrow i'm going
to be releasing all of the information
about how trump actually won illinois
which it's like of course he didn't
he never sent me the information some of
you may be maybe surprised to hear that
others probably are not surprised to
hear that
um
do i want to look at i have a ton of
other stuff to look at
but i i want to wait
because
there's just we just need there's a lot
of stuff happening here
ted cruz proposes armed cops in
elementary schools to deter shootings
was this today
we know from past experience that the
most effective tool for keeping kids
safe
is armed law enforcement on the campus
you know inevitably when there's a
murder of this kind
you see politicians try to try to
politicize it you see democrats and a
lot of folks in the media whose
immediate solution is to try to
restrict
the constitutional rights of law-abiding
citizens
i mean wasn't the shooter a law-abiding
citizen when he bought the guns and then
he went and used them for crimes i mean
that's that's the difficulty of the
situation right which is if i understand
correctly from what we know right now
the shooter on his 18th birthday went
and bought two guns
um here's kind of a weird question david
are you comfortable taking or making
money over the deaths of children listen
i have a stream and i have a youtube
channel this is my job lots of the
things we cover are negative events
and people are able to support what i do
for whatever reason they want i mean we
we cover stuff we were here on the day
of the trump riots
was i
making money from the riots i mean i
have no control over these events i
think it'd be a different case if i was
uh sensationalizing or responsible for
these events maybe you would have a
point
but
you know i mean is is anderson cooper
comfortable making money from this
we know car chases generate revenue
right i mean i i don't know
it's just kind of a weird weird
direction to go in
um
you know and by by the way
i would rather there be no shootings
you know and and and uh
would the audience be smaller i don't
even know but i would rather there not
be
uh the subject of the news is incidental
yeah i think that that's that's well
said it's kind of a weird
a little a little bit cringey i don't
know
will the january sixth hearings on
trump's coup affect the midterms should
it uh should dems make the coup attempt
and republican extremism a campaign
issue i don't know what's going to be
presented at those hearings yet
but my plan is to stream them live
and then we'll just we'll make that
assessment based on what there is thanks
to performance gaming as well for the um
for for the super chat as we stand by
here for joe biden any moment
david don't you know you're not allowed
to work any day anything bad happens
right yeah no if the news is negative
then i basically i guess i either can't
stream or we can't
uh be compensated for the work that we
do i don't know i don't know what what
people sort of expect it's a little a
little bit weird i admit a little bit
strange um let's see if i have anything
else here oh hold on let's go to oh no
we don't want that
um
oh i can't i can't i already i've
already addressed the whole mental
health stuff
so i'm not going to deal with that
here's steve kerr the coach of the
golden state warriors speaking about
what happened oh i'm not going to talk
about basketball nothing's
happened with our team last six hours
we're going to start the same way
tonight
any basketball questions don't matter
since we left shoot around 14 children
were killed 400 miles from here
and a teacher
and in the last 10 days we've had
elderly black people killed in a
supermarket
in buffalo we've had asian church-goers
killed
in southern california and now we have
children murdered at school
when are we gonna do something
i'm tired i'm i'm so tired of getting up
here and offering condolences to
to the
dev yeah sorry everybody i mean you know
we've tried nothing but we're out of
ideas and
there might just not be any way to
prevent something that only happens in
this country so thoughts and prayers you
know stated families that are out there
i'm so tired of the excuse me i'm sorry
i'm tired of the moments of silence
enough
there's 50 senators
right now who refuse to vote on hr8
which is a background check rule that
the house passed a couple years ago it's
been sitting there for two years
and there's a reason they won't vote on
it to hold on to power
so i ask you mitch mcconnell i ask all
of you senators who refuse to do
anything about the violence in school
shootings and supermarket shootings i
ask you but but isn't is is he using his
platform of basketball wrongly to talk
politics yeah
and uh if his team wants to fire him
they can do it and if you don't want to
go to a golden state warriors game
because of it you don't have to go
he's got a platform and he's using it
the way he wants to use it
i happen to agree with him if i didn't i
could i don't know boycott the golden
state warriors do whatever the hell you
want
are you going to put your own
desire for power ahead of the lives
of our children and our elderly and our
church-goers
because that's what it looks like
[Music]
it's what we do every week
so
i'm fed up i've had enough
we're gonna play the game tonight but i
want every person here every person
listening to this to think about your
own child or grandchild or mother or
father or sister brother how would you
feel if this happened to you today
we can't get numb to this we can't sit
here and just read about it and go well
tell a moment this is steve kerr
long time uh golden state warriors well
kind of he's been coaching the warriors
for a while
um
used to be on the chicago bulls which i
grew up watching does anybody remember
what years steve kerr was on the bulls
steve kerr chicago bulls
um
he was with the bulls i guess it would
have been for the
well so let's see jordan was 91 1983 and
45 for the 96 97 and 98 championships
during which i was absolutely riveted
some of the most fun basketball i've
ever seen arguably the best team ever
uh i mean has there been a better
basketball team than the bulls of of uh
96 97 and 98
anyway for silence yeah go dubs you know
come on mavs let's go that's what we're
going to do we're going to go play a
basketball game
and and 50 senators in washington are
going to hold us hostage
you realize that 90 of americans
regardless of political party want
background checks yeah and even when
democrats had the house senate and white
house it didn't pass personal
backgrounds 90 of us we are being held
hostage by 50 senators
in washington who refuse to even put it
to a vote despite
what we the american people want yep
they won't vote on it because they want
to hold on to their own power
it's pathetic i've had enough
so there is steve kerr with uh quite
frankly sometimes i joke and say that it
was a powerful declaration legitimately
a powerful declaration there and uh i
support him using his platform for
whatever he wants and listen if people
don't like it then just fight you know
the teen doesn't like it fire them
if the crowd doesn't like it don't go to
the games okay everybody can everybody
can vote with their dollars and tweets
and whatever they want this is what he
chose to do if you don't like it then
free market do whatever you want write
them and write them a nasty letter
um
okay
yeah let's uh yeah all right let's take
a look at some of the results here
mo brooks oh there's almost no none of
the vote in okay this is this is not
even meaningful yet with 0.1 percent of
the vote in mo brooks is losing but it's
so so so early
um still no data from sarah huckabee
sanders out of our kansas
brian kemp has won this is a loss for
trump okay
trump lost then he went donald trump
yeah donald trump right
and god bless
the united states and we will ban men
well they're not banning men but they've
certainly not chosen the man trump
endorsed trump endorsed david perdue
david perdue has been walloped okay
absolutely crushed under the weight
of brian kemp
and
massive dumps of votes coming in for
brian kemp it's been called it's over
trump lost here
okay
uh they are going to have to look very
strongly at those machines though that's
for damn sure we're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines so this is
a loss for donald trump meanwhile
marjorie taylor green
still doing quite well
still doing quite well
and
we are monitoring the vote count in
pennsylvania from last week although
they may be done for the day so that's
the latest update on the vote numbers
let me say thank you on such a
crazy day i appreciate all of you
joining me here i think we're close to
six or seven thousand people so far
joining me on all of our different
platforms joe biden is going to be
speaking any moment thanks to everybody
who's supporting today's stream that
includes foul mouth ripper eat the
living and friendly uncle over on twitch
very much appreciate that puts us at 23.
i want to say thanks to henry guzman
who just signed up on my website
joinedpakman.com using the coupon code
obama obama and then i want to say
thanks to simon reed blake daniel alex
ross and derek guin
each of them has just gifted a
membership meaning they bought a
membership on my website but they don't
want it they're saying david sir give it
to somebody else the four recipients are
are richard living good
uh
terry naylor
sean killum
and lyron delane
okay appreciate the four of you
and really appreciate everybody um
signing up on the website today super
chat's coming in hello david i believe
you may be missing your calling as a
perfect debate moderator you have a keen
ear
for what should and shouldn't be heard
seen or said thank you i appreciate that
bay photo says sir can you truth about
kemp's win on truth central oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah i don't know how many of uh of
y'all
are on truth essential truth sensual we
we might know it as truth social but
trump calls it truth central truth
essential it's his own social media
platform
i'm on there i've signed up on troth you
can see me there at d pacman you might
notice the website looks exactly like
twitter they've just copied twitter
um i'm just posting my thing on here
even though it's all right winger so
let's make a truth
uh
wow
david perdue absolutely
crushed brutally by massive dumps of
votes for brian kemp
in georgia what
a humiliating
loss
for the failed former president
donald trump
who endorsed
david perdue
truly an endorsement to be flushed down
the toilet
10 to 15 times all right guys i just
posted a truth
to truth
essential
yeah truth essential
president donald j trump
all right there it is so anyway
um
maybe i'll even tweet this as well just
i mean why not right
there we go
okay joe biden is going to be speaking
uh any second and we're going to we're
going to be covering those remarks live
this will be on the shooting that took
place in texas second deadliest school
shooting
uh since sandy hook
okay
and um
[Music]
the the the i hesitate to even call them
solutions being proposed by republicans
the responses include arming teachers
and putting more guns just out there
just guns everywhere put them everywhere
um
[Music]
david keep up the good work can i please
get an obama makes me chuckle every time
sure obama there you go
hope that did it for you
um
[Music]
yeah many many many many election
results that we're going to be looking
at uh we've been following them
let me see if i have
let's see i've got a couple voicemails
on the shooting
hi david i i am for a second amendment
but i'm sure you've heard 14 children
have been killed by us i hate the phrase
i'm for the second amendment it's like
we have a second amendment now we've got
to figure out how to reduce gun violence
that that phrase like
it the second amendment is
and okay
let's listen to more gunman in texas and
a teacher what are we gonna do there is
you've said this a couple of times i
completely agree there is an epidemic of
gun violence but it's so corrosive that
i feel like no one is safe anywhere
everybody wants so this is the same okay
you want to have a good guy with a gun
with a bad guy with a gun here's the bad
news i'm not convinced that there are
any good guys with guns okay we see
videos of brazilians just randomly
shooting like those uh a brazilian will
like try to rob a star and some random
doodle like shoot him and he'll all
right let's go uh let's go to joe biden
good evening fellow americans
i had hoped
when i became president i would not have
to do this
again
another massacre
uvalde texas
in elementary school
beautiful
innocent
second third fourth graders fellow
americans oh god
and how many scores of little children
who witness what happened
see their friends die
as if they're on a battlefield for god's
sake
they'll live with the rest of their
lives
there's a lot we don't know yet
there's a lot we do know
the parents who will never see their
child again
never have them jump in bed and cuddle
with them
parents will never be the same
to lose a child
it's like having a piece of your soul
ripped away
there's a hollowness in your chest you
feel like you're being sucked into it
you're never going to be able to get out
suffocated
it's never quite the same
it's a feeling shared by the siblings
and the grandparents and the family
members and the community that's left
behind
scripture says
that jill and i have talked about this
in different contexts
another
context the lord
is near to the brokenhearted
and saves the christian spirit
so many crushed spirits
so tonight
i ask the nation to pray for them
to give the parents and siblings the
strength
and the darkness they feel right now
as a nation we have to ask when in god's
name
are we going to stand up to the gun
lobby
when in god's name
we do we all know in our gut needs to be
done
this is 340
3448 days
10 years since i stood up at
a high school in connecticut a grade
school in connecticut
where another government massacred 26
people including 20 first graders at
sandy hook elementary school
since then
there have been over 900 incidents
of gunfire reported on school grounds
marjory stoneman douglas high school in
parkland florida
santa fe high school in texas
oxford high school in michigan
list goes on and on and this grows
when it includes mass shootings at
places like movie theaters houses of
worship
as we saw just 10 days ago at a grocery
store in buffalo new york
i am sick and tired of it
we have to act
and don't tell me
we can't have an impact on this carnage
i spent my career as a senator and a
vice president
working to pass common sense gun
laws we can won't prevent every tragedy
but we know they work
and have positive impact when we pass
the assault weapons ban
mass shootings went down
when the law expired mass shootings
tripled
the idea that an 18 year old kid
can walk into a gun store and buy two
assault weapons
it's just wrong
what in god's name do you need a solvent
for except to kill someone
deer aren't running through the
forest with kevlar vests on for god's
sake
it's just sick
and the gun manufacturers have spent two
decades aggressively marking assault
weapons which make them the most and
largest profit
for god's sake we have to have the
courage to stand up to the industry
here's what else i know
most americans support common sense laws
common sense gun laws
i just got off
my trip from asia meeting with
asian leaders
and i learned of this while i was on the
aircraft
and what struck me
on that
17-hour flight
what struck me
was these kinds of mass shootings rarely
happen anywhere else in the world
true
why
they have mental health problems right
they have domestic disputes in other
countries
they have people who are lost
but these kinds of masculinities never
happen with the kind of frequency that
happened in america why correct why are
we willing to live with this carnage
why don't we keep letting this happen
where in god's name is our backbone
to have the courage to deal with and
stand up to the lobbies
it's a time to turn this pain into
action
for every parent for every citizen in
this country
we have to make it clear to every
elected official in this country it's
time to act
it's time for those who obstruct or
delay
or block the common-sense gun laws we
need to let you know
that we will not forget
we can do so much more
we have to do more
our prayer tonight
was those parents
lying in bed and trying to figure out
will i be able to sleep again
what do i say to my other children
what happens tomorrow
may god bless the loss of innocent life
on this sad day
and may the lord be near the
brokenhearted and save those
christian spirit
because they're going to need a lot of
help
a lot of our prayers
god love you
[Music]
will you go to texas sir the president's
saying may god bless the loss of
innocent life on this day glory borger
and david axelrod join me here uh in new
york david what a what a disastrous day
what a disastrous day
and i mean think of the absurdity of joe
biden is saying
we got to take control back from these
lobbies including you know the gun
lobbies what he's referring to
and this weekend greg abbott is
scheduled to speak
at the nra convention
okay greg abbott the governor of texas
where this happened he's scheduled to
speak at the nra convention
uh
it's it's
it's absolutely insane
absolutely insane so okay we dealt with
that
uh joe biden with a brief statement
there
um
and in about 10 minutes we're going to
have a bunch more
election results and we're going to look
at them
momentarily i do want to play a couple
more of your voicemails and then we're
going to have additional results i do
want to say thanks on twitch to beef
stews katsuomo
talks go
m z frazzled
sven hout
so tool fan and yo samurai
for the subscriptions i really
appreciate that
i also want to say thanks to jody elder
and desiree delong
for signing up on my website um
we're going to be here we're going to be
here covering all of the stuff the
elections everything that's going on
and uh i would love it if you signed up
at joinedpakman.com
um i'll shout everybody out and we will
continue coverage of everything that's
taking place let's get the latest
numbers
uh mo brooks has now um
it's just half of one percent of the
vote so it's still very early i don't
know that we can glean too much from
this but mo brooks is sort of the cart
i guess you could say the cartoonish
right winger
although they're all kind of cartoonish
we're monitoring this this is alabama
in arkansas uh with 11 percent of the
vodan
trump's former press secretary sarah
huckabee sanders jumps out to a pretty
solid lead she's expected to win easily
as far as i know
this is our kansas
and then in georgia
it has been called for brian kemp donald
trump endorsed david perdue
the gubernatorial republican primary
winner easily easily easily easily
is brian kemp this is a loss for donald
trump
and meanwhile marjorie taylor greene
imminently going to be called the winner
of her primary she is um 55 points ahead
with 40 of the vote in i believe it's
over there
and marcus flowers on the democratic
side
um also likely to win
in minnesota there's a special election
i don't know the significance of it and
we have no results so my instinct is
we're not going to be talking too too
much about minnesota tonight
we also have this interesting race here
in texas's 28th district
where the incumbent henry cuellar
is being challenged by jessica cisneros
it is very tight with 68 percent of the
vote in it is
51.48 right now more like 52.48
um
you can't see the percents
i i don't know what you mean by that
oh the right side oh oh oh oh sorry
sorry sorry sorry
whoops okay
so sorry these were the numbers we were
looking at
i had the wrong uh element up on the
screen i apologize
okay so marjorie's at 70 there
and then we're watching this one closely
and they are still counting ballots in
pennsylvania
from a week ago okay so we are following
that as well
super chat's coming in always always
thank you for your lives thanks
blueberry appreciate that
sherman says tucker carlson is saying
biden is politicized the texas shooting
in his speech tucker carlson's a
horrible person
whose opinions are worth uh
very very little
let's just put it that way
this is cameron caskey good guy guy i
know have met him before let's listen to
what he's saying for which of course
seeing that kind of empathy from a
leader is certainly something we weren't
seeing from 2016 to 2020 but joe biden
is the president of the united states
there is a weapon that has been
unleashed upon the united states the
creator of which has said is not meant
for civilian use and he talks about how
sad it is offers some thoughts and
prayers
and says that it's bad that mass
violence happens and it's great that he
thinks that it's bad but i can tell you
that gun control organizers people who
believe in gun safety common sense gun
safety laws around the country were
waiting to hear the words executive
order and instead we heard the words
essentially thoughts and prayers
when something yeah let me address
something guys because something kind of
ugly is going on earlier in the stream i
received a super chat
that said
um hey david i'm native american
and i'm not going to vote
until these politicians do something for
me
and i said i disagree with that i
believe that
the way to get them to pay attention
is by voting the voting is the starting
point and i actually just respectfully
disagreed and i said i would reconsider
that i would say
vote and also demand action
i got an email from someone saying
you suggested indigenous people who
don't vote don't have a right to
complain no no no you have every right
to complain
i i i just literally never said that
i just didn't say that criticize me for
things i've said not think i didn't say
can you imagine
you native americans don't have a right
to complain
that is in no
universe anything i would ever say on
this show anyone who knows me at all
should re
i would never say that that is not
anything i would ever say
what i said was i disagree with the idea
of saying
until politicians do things for me
i won't vote i just won't participate
that i i just think that that's bad
strategy i
i didn't say you don't have a right to
complain everybody has a right to
complain
uh and they're saying i was just that it
was this this person says i disrespected
and did you you're misunderstanding or
misstating what i said
not something i would ever say
okay
um
these parents are crushed in spirit in
ways i hope i will never know
and i believe that for myriad reasons we
are a nation of crushed spirits i know i
am one
when the mx-5 the army's replacement for
the m4ar15
starts showing up at these vile events
the carnage will be much worse
it's much more powerful
there seem to be uh
oh i just got an interesting email
actually i think if you'll if you'll
allow me
i think um i want to mention let's see
uh
many parents seem more mad about masks
in schools
than guns in schools
that make sense is this the way you
would word this tweet is it am i getting
the idea across correctly
or anybody anybody have a suggestion for
rewording this
people like it okay
no some people are saying
you would rewrite it
many maga parents okay
sounds like i'm talking about the
parents who were victims today does it i
don't want it to sound that way
ah we'll bail okay yeah let's just bail
on it that's fine now if people think
it's no good we'll skip it i'm totally
willing to be uh directed on that
um
it's not really a hot take everybody's
aware of that yeah fair fair
okay more super chats coming in
um let's see here david sir deepest
sympathies to the united states again
have americans ever heard of referendum
they work ireland here is a testament to
that in recent years
uh okay and thanks stephanie there all
right let's take another look at the
election results this was actually
supposed to be an election results
stream but the shooting happened and
then biden spoke and then etc mo brooks
is still losing in alabama sarah
huckabee sanders is quite easily winning
for now in arkansas but that's only with
15 percent of the vote in
brian kemp has defeated david perdue in
the republican gubernatorial primary in
georgia brian kemp was endorsed by mike
pence david perdue was endorsed by
donald trump
marjorie taylor greene
easily winning her primary and will
almost certainly almost certainly face
marcus flowers although neither of those
races has yet been called and in texas
we are very closely watching the henry
kweller jessica cisneros race it's a
runoff in the
28th district i'm going to refresh just
because it hasn't updated for a while
uh
and nope it legitimately hasn't updated
okay there's just been no new data for a
little bit fine
um we're going to continue
watching all of this
um
okay
very good
we are standing by yeah several counties
have not yet reported it's early it's
it's still early in a lot of these
places for sure
thanks to blueberry babe and ir geek
for the subscriptions and the gift that
puts us at 40. i also want to say a big
thank you to steve hoyt steve just
gifted a membership over at
joinedpakman.com i really appreciate
that steve i'm going to give that
membership away
to uh
who is it here
to vilma queller presumably no relation
to henry kweller ville mcqueller if you
want a free membership just put your
name in it davidpakman.com
free membership and then if you're able
to gift a membership you can do that on
my website joinpakman.com
when you go through the sign up process
just check the box that says is this a
gift
make sure to get yourself a membership
before you give any away and you can use
the coupon code obama
to get a discount i think the normal
prices are very reasonable but by all
means anybody who wants a discount can
take a discount and the website where
all of that goes down is join pacman.com
david says i made a troth central
account and instantly got followed by
almost two dozen accounts looks like
bots are running rampant there too we'll
see how long my account lasts it's
called trump or tantrum yeah let's see
how people are responding
um
to my
message i put up here truth essential
yeah
um
truth sensual
so true i'm watching your stream obama
may need a 16th flush
what do you what's that make trump 81-3
yeah real loser numbers loser wait until
you hear the real brian kemp story guys
does anybody know what the real brian
kemp story is that isn't being told
anybody have any idea
hmm sort of curious
um
truth central will censor trump's bigly
loss will trump endorse abrams
dumps stop the machines that's a popular
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines there it is love
the stream
uh
the hell is this i don't even know what
this was
that was weird all right we're gonna get
away from that it got a little strange
at the bottom there we're gonna get away
from that
um
[Music]
okay
yeah couple other voicemails coming in
about the shooting here's the
eggman hey dave
i don't know why biden has such a low
approval rating
i approve of joe biden's
job in office right now
i just watched him speak after the
shooting in texas and i have to tell you
which shooting
and he talks about losing your child
yeah you know what's crazy tomorrow on
the show
i'll have to say
we have to talk about the shooting
but i don't mean the buffalo one
i i mean this other shooting
and you know referencing his son or his
daughter for that matter and um
i don't know he's he's not a bad guy and
i can't imagine
a republican president getting up there
speaking to america like that
um
i hope he doesn't run again but you know
he's doing a good job
shalom yeah i mean who's the last
republican president who could speak
with some empathy
i mean i guess in some way george w bush
had it
a little bit of a way about him where
where he seemed mildly
uh able to empathize mildly
yeah bush kinda did it people seemed to
i mean it was great
uh a lot of the things he had to show
empathy for were disasters of his own
creation like sending people to iraq
on the false premise that iraq had
something to do with 911 and had weapons
of mass destruction
um
yeah no it's uh
it's something
here's another uh
let's see what's going on here another
call about i'm going to be kind of i'm
kind of
pre-screening some of these
because with something so sensitive i
don't want to air something crazy
hey david this is nikki colorado
i watched today's
um podcast in reference to
[Music]
the gun violence especially what we saw
in the news this morning in texas
and i just wanted to give you a quick
call to let you know that i found on um
elections.bradyunited.org
there's a really interesting um little
section here that says which senators
have taken the most nra money
and it has a list you know of all the
republican senators all the senators
that have gotten money over the years
and then it has this cool little
um
tweet sim
button that you can click that button
under whichever senator
and then it takes you straight into
twitter
and then you can then
automatically tweet this really really
cool tweet okay all right that's
something to look into yeah that's
something to look into
um
okay
uh
i think okay i've got one more here
hello david sorry if i am emotional
uh this is anna from miami
yeah anna's argentinian but she she's in
miami
but i'm again in horror
and i just want to tell you something
that of course you you won't be able to
wear this message and it's not
my intention oh wait i'm not supposed to
air this
all right i guess if she doesn't want i
mean
we say on the voice oh man we say on the
voicemail if you leave a message it it's
eligible for air don't don't call if you
don't want it with peace and love anna
um please don't call if you don't want
it aired the whole point of the the only
point of the voicemail line is to air
the voicemails but i'll just because
it's
normally i would pre-screen it but we're
just going to move on okay
robbie says watching dallas texas
results for u.s congress jasmine
crockett is winning and she has bernie's
endorsement all right we will check that
out saw some encouraging demographic
changes leading into 2024 could you
investigate
uh okay
i will look into that
okay not going to do stock advice here
sir my reply to your truth was already
taken down they're canceling me on the
free speech platform yeah there's not as
much free speech on truth central
as some might imagine as some might
imagine thanks to both staff and brains
as well as see missile for the twitch
subscriptions very much appreciate that
also thank you to midnight hunter who
just signed up at joinpakman.com and his
new member number 44 and steve hoyt who
just gifted a subscription that's number
45 that subscription goes to
uh gia oris
who has requested a free subscription
which i uh very much appreciate that
um right side broadcasting has just gone
live
at loser david perdue's
uh party
uh wait a second let's see here
right side
broadcasting
this i have to see
um
oh my god it's over
it looks like they canceled the stream
this i have to see let's see you're bad
side you don't want and he's very he's
very professional but he is he was he's
very sharp tongued and so we want to
wish him luck as well as he we're going
to be live all night from the purdue
victory party purdue got crushed did
they just be coming up on his uh
programming note like i said earlier liz
and i will be in casper wyoming uh this
saturday for president trump's rally
there in wyoming uh a few more i think
are going to be announced here in the
short days so we'll keep up to date on
all of our social media as you know
president trump's on there on on
the campaign convention nra convention
houston that is on the 24th so look
we're looking forward to
can
today is the 24th can you imagine after
what happened today trump's going to go
speak at the nra convention oh my god so
does anybody know what happened did they
just cancel the stream because their guy
lost bringing you president trump's
speech from that as well yeah and once
again our thoughts and prayers go on to
all of the families affected by the
shooting earlier
our thoughts and prayers go out to the
families affected trump will be speaking
at the nra today in uvalde texas just in
south texas along the border there uh
confirmed dead obviously multiple
casualties and children and and adults
so we want to thoughts and prayers on
that and continue to
pray for that and i would imagine that
that conversation is now going to be
injected into political uh discussions
uh well yeah because we've got to do
something i mean with are the thoughts
and prayers
prophylactic in some way if people
prayed correctly
would it prevent the shooting or do we
only pray after the disaster maybe we
could do something to prevent some of
these of gun control and the need for
gun control and they're gonna that's
gonna be the the pounding of the drum
probably until we get to november but uh
i heard a great stout the other day liz
and i think i told you this earlier out
of all the gun mass shootings we've ever
seen not one nra card holder has done it
these are these are can i say oh i
almost slipped these are punks these are
disgusting demonic people
yes they have they're not cardinal oh my
god this is beyond parody i can't
believe they're doing this holders of
the nra so let's get that clear it's not
uh rifle gun owners but uh that by the
way most gun owners are not nra members
uh number of nra members
um
at the absolute most like four years ago
it's believed the nra had five million
members and it's believed that that
number has declined
so why does it i mean
most gun owners aren't nra members why
why does that even matter that is a
great program note for friday we'll be
live in houston for that and then of
course on saturday we'll be in casper
wyoming and then so follow us on two
social and get her i mean let's go
savasone truth social what what the hell
did he just say and give our handles out
for people uh that want to we'll
continue to push out these notifications
throughout the night absolutely um our
network is at rsb network on getter and
twitter and on to social it's just at
rsbn our personal ones on twitter is at
liz willis
underscore and on getter it's liz willis
truth socialist atlas i'm sorry i made
it difficult but you're at brian glenn
tv across all platforms yeah and then at
brian on truth social we we got kind of
lucky on truth social we got in there
really really early and i was able to
get just to at brian
so it makes it really simple
it's cool there's there's only one at
least in the whole entire world that's
you should go to his so
the reason we're watching this is they
were going to be live at david perdue's
results thing and david perdue lost and
it looks like they already called it a
night
you would give it up you would
willingly give that up i would give it
to you yeah and i would give it up to
anybody else that brian but we're so
glad you're joining us tonight once
again share this broadcast as it's over
uh and tag a friend because liz you you
and i know
william just emailed me saying that he
was watching
right side and that they shut down the
stream saying they were taking a quick
break okay well did they did they say
that and just cancel people throughout
our our our career and going to
different states and different cities
and
and people we want to make sure that
people get the information that we have
so tell a friend tag them in a
conversation tell them about right side
yeah and come out to a rally if we're if
we're at a all right anyway so i guess
they just bailed let's see if they're
going live again no it doesn't seem like
it
doesn't seem like it it seems like they
just bailed on the entire thing when
their guy lost wow that's that's pretty
crazy
that's pretty wild oh here's info on the
uh texas 28th which we're following so
much james homan let's go to mary beth
albright who is tracking redistricting
changes around the country and has more
on we missed it but we have the the
numbers there
um
jessica cisneros just slightly ahead of
the incumbent henry kweller by 1.6
percentage points that is very close
it has now gone official marjorie
taylor-green has secured the republican
nomination in georgia's 14th district
she will likely face marcus flowers
although the marcus flowers race has not
yet been called but probably
a brian kemp
not endorsed by trump in fact opposed by
trump has won easily in the georgia
republican gubernatorial primary
sarah huckabee sanders inevitably will
be the winner in the gubernatorial
republican primary in arkansas
and mo brooks it's not looking too good
for mo brooks in the senate republican
primary in alabama so we're watching a
lot of these different uh races
and
different things happening in different
ones
let's look at some other
super chats just bought the domain truth
essential what should i do with it do
you want it no i'm just too busy make a
satirical fake truth social that'd be
kind of funny
uh if you do something with it let us
know
thanks jesse for the super chat
don't forget the nra recently
reincorporated in the great gun freedom
state of texas yes they did
that's very true they they did do that
um
okay
let's see a couple other voicemails
coming in
hi david i was calling about the gun
reform if we can't do gun reform can we
possibly do ammunition reform maybe make
it like
can't amount to having a
live boy or dead girl in your trunk like
some legal rule on amy you know i've
researched that quite a bit
there are many it's one of those
disagreements where many claim many many
many claim
that
the right to firearms
includes the right to ammunition for
those firearms that the firearms with no
ammunition it's not like if you make it
insanely difficult to get ammunition
that it would violate the second
amendment is the argument that's often
made i'm not a lawyer so i've just read
those opinions that you can't make it
you know one idea is like make the chris
rock idea make the bullets five grand
each and then you'll be damn sure
someone deserved it if they get shot
right that was a joke that chris rock
had years ago
um
from what i've read it would be
considered a restriction on the second
amendment to do that
uh
because it would place an undue bird
burden on gun owners
i know what you're getting out there
um
let's see what else we've got here
juan called in
hey david swann uh
it was kind of hard for me to figure out
what to say about the shooting um
it's certainly something that
shouldn't have happened and um true
i support
the second amendment but
i don't support
just uh
this type of stuff um who does
and i don't have a gun i never intended
to have a gun and i don't plan to have a
gun
um
it's sad
and i'm thankful in a way that i don't
have kids
anyway uh
have a good one and consider unbanning
me from youtube man i made some stupid
uh comments yeah juan i already told you
we will unban you from youtube but
you've got to email us a link to your
youtube profile okay so you've got to
email info davidpakman.com
with a link to your youtube profile
if you do that we will be able to unban
you okay do we know if the texas shooter
had a manifesto or is the motivation
unknown as of right now
no
we i am not aware of any manifesto i am
not aware of any known motive
as of right now
okay
if we
learn anything else
we will have it for you
thanks to actual one hersafat
l doc
boshimonos margot cabot kristen gooding
for the twitch subscriptions that puts
us at 51. i really appreciate that i
also want to say a huge thank you
to i can't tell if it's jan kaiser or
jan kaiser but either way
uh
i appreciate you signing up at
joinpacman.com and your new member
number 52 today 52
and i invite you to sign up on my
website
joinpakman.com
david big canadian fan here keep up the
good work voices like yours are very
important to your democracy thank you i
really appreciate that
uh let's take a listen to what's going
on here and i know we've talked about
mental health
but the children who survived the
families who did not lose
children as well as those that lost them
but the police officers that had to
respond and then process the scene
i mean this is horrific i mean every
aspect of this particular case there's
just absolutely no question about it
this is something
that people are going to struggle with
for a very long time and sometimes you
hear people talk about healing you don't
heal from stuff like this you just don't
and i think with juliet that mentioned
earlier you know there are many people
that you know when they watch television
they see crime scenes those are
sanitized versions you work the street
you see what it really looks like and i
can only imagine unfortunately
weapons is devastating as assault
rifles ripping through the bodies of
children and the kind of damage that it
causes and what that scene has to look
like i mean this is something that
believe me people need to understand
just how devastating this is
and and hopefully there'll be some
action taken although i'm not optimistic
that there'll be any action taken uh
unfortunately um
um
julia i mean just over a week ago 10
people were killed in buffalo as you
mentioned
what
i mean
i don't even know if it makes sense to
talk about trying to protect
targets like this but i mean again we're
talking about schools and we're talking
about a supermarket so to call them
targets i mean
everything by that definition is a
target
right i mean life is a target when you
have this kind of weaponry out there and
just and that is uh that's the reality
and we we sanitize it i mean i sanitize
it i i say killer and and not gunman
it's a gunman i mean it's someone who
uses a gun to kill 18 children who as
chief ramsey was reminding us as we've
been all reminding us what is happening
right now it's 9 19 p.m
and we haven't had really a very good
press conference i'll tell you what's
happening there's
18 little bodies that have been
destroyed and decimated and i'm going to
be clear here uh by a gun uh that is
meant to do that but these are young
bodies and they are not they do not have
identification they're not you know
they're not carrying wallets and uh
their parents know that they haven't
survived because their parents aren't
unified with them and their parents as
every parent knows is the only person
who can probably identify that child
right now the birthmark on the thigh the
the crooked toe you know whatever it is
that we know about our kids that no one
else would know that wouldn't be in a
in a sanitary sanitized uh
medical report and that's what's
happening that's why it's 9 20 p.m and
the three of us have been on air for i
think about seven hours um and i just
have to say it again and this this is
this is what's happening inside that
room and when we talk about
the sh you know the gunman's motives and
guns that's all important and it's
important because
this is what happened i mean this is
this is our american this is our you
know american
rinse and repeat this is what we do
and racine is reporting that meta
formerly facebook is in contact with law
enforcement and took down an account
possibly associated with this gunman
we don't have much more information
other than that we know in buffalo
there was all right so a lot of
different types of uh
comments and speculation and and
different things
going on here
uh
oh completely horrifying stuff
um
people
continue calling in
hello david this is
aaron and i think they were an assault
weapons restriction
just the age of 25
would pass pretty easily
and like like they're talking about
bands
and it never happens because they
overreach
i think every time
yeah i just don't know that republicans
would go for anything i mean very
obvious things just republicans don't go
for it it's it's not it's just not that
simple
hey david this is uh jake from
pennsylvania
and just watching the all the
information going on about the
another
mass shooting and already seeing the
rhetoric going on for people on the
right and as someone who was raised in a
very christian red rural area in
missouri i can tell you that
so much of these people that lived in
these areas were lived and
were
fed
the
from church
local officials everybody and that the
only way the only people doing these
mass shootings or cleaning these types
of crimes were either immigrants or
they were people who
some literally believe their possessed
or influenced by the devil yep yeah this
is the story they tell each other and
themselves
and that they're mostly democrats and
the only way
to fight against it
was to uh
okay they got cut off
this is why i sewed military-grade
bulletproof armor plates into my kids
backpacks i don't know if chase is
how depraved is the situation in the
united states that i don't know if chase
is kidding like if a danish viewer
said that i would go obviously you're
kidding no danish parent feels the need
to sew military-grade armor plates into
their kids backpack but the fact that
this is an american presumably they're
sending the super chat in us dollars
i i don't know whether that's a joke
maybe they did
maybe they did make a sort of
bulletproof shield
out of their kids backpack
they sell backpacks that are armored
yeah i've seen that
somebody plagiarized your tweet on
twitter
um there's like a billion people on
twitter so that's not super useful
you're also not telling me which tweet
so unfortunately that's not a very
instructive
super chat
we're going to take another look at the
election results in six minutes at the
bottom of the hour i want to say thanks
to puppy.exe
for the twitch prime subscription your
subscriber number 53 today i also can't
tell you i am
flattered and inspired by the people
that are signing up on my website today
as you some of you saw me tweet earlier
we are in the crosshairs of big social
media again
instagram
for some reason completely unbeknownst
to me
has sort of limited our account because
we share covet disinformation and the
videos that they've identified as
sharing coveted disinformation are
actually videos in which i debunk
disinformation
so we're now limited on instagram
another tool
where we are
i mean listen
they should limit covet disinformation
on the platform
we're debunking it okay so
now we gotta try to deal with that so in
any case i'm really appreciative of
everybody who's signing up
tucker mccloskey is a new member on my
website
robert wagner is a new member
janice daly just signed up and kurt
feldman is a new member at
joinpacman.com
that puts us at 57 for the day i also
want to say a huge thank you to simon
reed
simon has just gifted a subscription to
someone else and i will give that the
script subscription to the next person
in line that's michael rose okay michael
you'll get an email in the next day or
two telling you how to take advantage of
it and simon gifting one more
that's number 59
and i will gift that one to the next
person in line and that's paula allen
all right thank you everybody
very very much
appreciate that
um
let's see here
um
why was the texas shooter aged 18
shooting in an elementary school with
ages 5 to 11 there doesn't seem to be a
link
that's an that's actually a very good
question has anybody seen that addressed
like in other words
we watched the steve kerr response
earlier yeah do is is anything even
known about the can we just don't know
yet it's too early to tell i think
that's the issue it's just too early to
say
the gunman shot his grandmother before
attacking the school
i did see that
maybe we should have supported beto
moore myself included biden has been
handling the speeches consistently well
but
come on man
i think i've got that
come on man yeah
i think biden did fine
why isn't every commentator on tv saying
nothing is happening with gun control
because of the gop
everyone needs to call them out biden
did not call the republicans out by name
disappointing agreed
agreed 100
kemp winning should be good for abrams
no unless trump endorses kemp uh tbd i i
think it's just too early to say
um i don't i don't think we can say that
with certainty at this point let's
listen to some of the coverage on
washington post they're at a bunch of
the different results watch parties
victory parties etc president of the
united states libby all right thank you
so much carmela boykin let's bring
michael shearer into the conversation
national political reporter you know
michael as i watched some of the ads
coming out of georgia
governor kemp was in the same breath
bashing purdue and stacey abrams right
to two people who couldn't be farther
from each other on the political
spectrum but he's been gearing up for
the general election as we're hearing a
supporter talk about
already uh for a while before even
getting through today
i want to hear from you about the
concerns that some mainstream
republicans have had about president
trump
and what some have called his personal
vendetta
tour
talk to us about what the personal
vendetta tour is and what some of the
republican mainstream republican
leadership has has been concerned about
well you know we're seeing just this
month uh real institutions of power with
the republican party stand up and push
back on the president former president
uh for the first time since uh
at least to this extent since shortly
after the january six
insurrection the republican governors
association
uh came out strongly against a number of
uh the president's endorsements all
right so we basically uh we basically
know all of that
um okay it is the bottom of the hour
let's get to
um let's get to where the results stand
as of right now mo brooks has closed the
gap with katie britt
in alabama's senate republican primary
okay
in arkansas sarah huckabee sanders
trump's former
press secretary continues to lead by a
roughly four to one margin over francis
washburn she will almost certainly win
brian kemp endorsed by mike pence has
won the
georgia republican gubernatorial primary
very important race trump endorsed
purdue this is a loss for trump
marjorie taylor green has won in georgia
in the 14th district she will in all
likelihood face marcus flowers in
november who is easily winning easily
easily winning the 14th district
democratic primary
in texas
um
i am still seeing that jessica cisneros
is ahead but someone told me that cnn
has it differently uh they don't have it
on screen
let's see if i can find that cnn texas
28th district primary
let's see what they show
that is absolutely true
they show
with 63 percent reporting
well the thing about that is if we look
at the cnn numbers it's with less data
cnn says with 63 percent reporting
queller is ahead he's the incumbent
whereas politico with 70 reporting says
that cisneros is ahead
uh so i think we're just going to have
to wait there
it seems i mean but both of these are
very very close
and uh
we're gonna we're just gonna have to
wait and see there
uh
okay yeah some random person is copying
my tweets i i don't care that's fine
please open the chat feature new
subscriber says cali
i don't know what anybody know what that
means cali says please open the chat
feature new subscriber
i have no idea what that means
okay
i want to say thanks to steve hoyt who
just gifted a membership
steve hoyt who gifted another membership
and steve who gifted a third one steve
gifting three memberships i'm going to
give those away they just go in order
i'm not picking
uh
okay hold on
michael parkinson
trevor cassells
and tony smith
all get free memberships
thanks to those gifts
i appreciate that very much oh this is
the same guy fred gutenberg who was on
msnbc earlier let's take a listen sadly
now too many parents know
this is a particular kind of loss
yeah
it's violent
anderson
i'm a father
who hopes his daughter died instantly
because if she didn't that means she
suffered
that's the reality of loss to gun
violence
and
i'm a father
because i know the details i live
with my daughter's final second seared
in my head
i was on the phone with my son
convincing him to run because he wanted
to turn around
to find and save his sister
and while i was on the phone with him he
heard the bullets that killed his sister
so yeah gun violence is different
and
maybe that's why the failure and i'm
going to call them out it's the
republican party at least this guy will
do it
maybe that's why the failure to do
anything
is so despicable so evil
it's maybe that's why the news
that the texas governor lieutenant
governor the texas senators
are all attending the nra convention
this friday right hurts so much yep
because they have every opportunity
to change direction
they've had every opportunity for years
but they haven't
and so
listen
i just want to say this
my friend senator chris murphy has been
heroic today
i have hope
that someone in the republican party or
or all 50 democrats
will band together
and finally do something
because
the failure to do so only means the next
time there's a really good chance it's
going to be someone they love right
you have
you have gone to congress you have sat
and correct me if i'm wrong in ted
cruz's office
yes talk to him
what
what do you what did you say
ted cruz
uh
he should resign
you know after the previous instances
that have happened in texas he has
minimized he has
made excuses he has blamed everything
but the gun
and
he has sat with me
where i have told him
i have no issue with the second
amendment or legal lawful gun owners
i have an issue
with the ability of those who intend
harm to themself or someone else to get
weapons
and
he knows
doing something about gun violence is
not an affront to the second amendment
he knows doing something about gun
violence isn't
doesn't involve people walking into
people's homes and removing all of their
guns okay he knows all that but he
shares the lie because he is supported
by a profit making lobby
um
i have no faith in him i have no faith
that he will be the one to do the right
thing
i certainly hope he will
but i'm not counting on it
um but there are others
who i think might
and i i do hope in this moment
um
you know i saw mitt romney
putting out some messages of alarm
i've spoken to mitt romney
and i've heard mitt romney after i spoke
to him say we're not going to do
anything about guns in this body
i hope today mitt romney changes his
mind doubt it
fred gutenberg i appreciate your time
tonight and
thank you for being with us
thank you
next to precisely the question of what
if anything lawmakers might be able to
agree on this time yeah it's just uh
i mean
it's sort of like just to bottom line it
if it didn't happen after sandy hook
then is is it ever going to happen i
don't know
i don't know a badge asks wouldn't it be
quicker to gift memberships
automatically rather than manually
approve them yeah unfortunately it's
just it's a new part of our system and i
just don't have that ability
um we are working on some updates to the
website and that will certainly be part
of it but i don't have that ability
right now
thanks to raided roy as well as nikki
for the twitch subscriptions numbers 63
and 64. voicemails are pouring in
pouring in about what's happening
electorally and what is happening
with the horrible horrible shooting
uh ken paxton has defeated george p bush
in the
texas attorney general republican
primary so it's not looking great for
george p bush
that's i think jeb's son if i recall
correctly let's listen to a voicemail
hi david i'm watching your live stream
um
about the
midterms slash shooting
um
i think that lady that was just on the
anderson show had it uh pretty right
about talking about
the um
how morbid it is to have to go identify
a child because
all right i apologize for interrupting
but let's go to the brian camp event
uh outside houston we're gonna go now to
governor brian kemp and his victory
speech
[Applause]
all right let's give it up for amy
porter
obama
what a great night to be a georgian
everybody
i think we need to start tonight by
giving a big round of applause to the
best first lady in the country marty
kemp
please proceed governor
marty and i are so blessed to be here
with you all tonight and especially to
have our three daughters with us jared
lucy and amy porter we are so proud of
them y'all thank y'all for your hard
work and what you have been doing
you all know we started this journey as
a family and i couldn't be more thankful
to have these four kemp strong ladies by
my side through it all so believe it or
not this is the slightly less crazy guy
trump endorsed the really crazy guy who
lost david perdue here they have been
great warriors for us as well thank you
guys
looking at the results tonight it looks
like king team kemp has chopped a lot of
wood over the last few months
and i will tell you we could not be more
thankful
for the countless hours that all of you
have poured into this primary race
the doors the dials the small dollar
donations the yard signs and going to
events
you name it and king team kemp has done
it so thank you all so much
and as we have always said
team kemp has always been built from the
grassroots up and this race has been no
different
you have honored us with your time with
your efforts and with your resources but
most importantly with your belief in our
campaign and we cannot thank you guys
enough god bless you all thank you
is that it
no okay
back when i first ran for the state
senate as a local construction guy in
athens who was fed up with government
bureaucracy
there were a lot of people that said i
wouldn't be the be the incumbent state
senator
but i knew better
i knew that hard-working georgians felt
the same way that i did
that government was too big
and politicians were not listening
and that's why i ran
and i promised voters i would get
government out of the way
and ensure that georgia's best and
brightest days were still ahead
that i would put them first ahead of the
status quo and the politically correct
and that when i got into office i would
do exactly as i promised on the campaign
trail
and because of a lot of people in this
room
we won that race and we delivered on
those promises
in
2017 the same pundit said we couldn't
win the governor's race
but once again marty and the girls and i
we knew different you see i had been to
all 159 counties in the state
driving around in that green machine
that amy porter mentioned
i know you all have seen it
and i slept on more than a few sofas and
we ate at just about every diner and
meeting three that we came across
and i wasn't worried about what the
political class had to say
because i was listening to the waitress
at the barbecue barbecue joint and
wren's
i was listening to that dirt farmer in
dawson
in blairsville
and the people of quitman county who
just wanted a grocery store in their
community so they wouldn't have to drive
across the state line oh a dirt farmer
is like a subsistence farmer who barely
makes enough to survive okay i didn't i
had no idea what that meant yeah it's a
turn term apparently communities and
strong families they're not literally
farming dirt me they didn't want more of
the same
they wanted someone who would fight for
them and for their values
someone who would put them
first voters wanted someone that would
look them in the eye and tell them the
truth and then do what they said they
would do that's insane so in april of
2017
i did what a lot of people said i
shouldn't have done
we did what we felt we were called to do
and you know what we were right
nuclear proliferation
since our family has been honored to
serve you
we have accomplished so much
and there's so many in this room that
i've been serving with that's helped us
do that and i want to thank you all for
your support and your leadership we have
a great team in our state
no one could have predicted the
unprecedented challenges that we would
all face together
but we hunkered down and we emerged
stronger than ever
and we stood up for life at the
heartbeat
we cracked down on gangs and human
trafficking
we expanded access to rural broadband
so needless to say i'll be supporting
stacey abrams in the general election in
november it will be brian kemp against
stacy abrams and what an opportunity
what an opportunity to knock out an
incumbent republican
and replace him in this particular case
with someone
genuinely
really capable smart with great
political instincts an activist
stacey abrams so that will be in
november
one of the many races that we're going
to be following very closely
michael says can we hear trump
mispronouncing some words uh sure
i've got um
you know one of the things i have which
i've got to organize is trump
mispronouncing indian names is very good
swami vivek
[Applause]
yes exactly
as many of you might know i us i believe
trump is the only president in history
that mispronounced
another president's name
his own name and his own social media
platform okay then he went donald trump
yeah donald trump
obama truth essential okay so anyway
unique in that way for sure
um i think i missed another super chat
here hold on a second
is trump going to endorse abrams
uh
kemp is putting on his best good old boy
voice
is trump going to endorse abrams now
yeah right i i somehow i don't think so
but uh if he does i will certainly let
you know that's uh that's that's for
sure do people want to go back and
listen to more brian kemp or should we
just move on and check on results
elsewhere in the country
do we want to listen to this
all right we're moving on okay let's get
an update on the numbers a very slow
vote count happening in alabama
um
mo brooks now at 29 katie britt winning
at 44
in arkansas it's over sarah huckabee
sanders has won she will be
the republican nominee for the
governorship in arkansas in november
in georgia as we were just watching
brian kemp has won
in georgia's 14th district marjorie
taylor green has won and marcus flowers
will soon win and they will face each
other in november
in texas
jessica cisneros maintaining a 3.6
percent lead 3.6 percentage point lead
over henry cuellar per politico
over on cnn
uh very different numbers
uh but still stuck at only 63 percent
has queller up by five
i think we we have to assume that the
results with 73 are more accurate than
the 63 right it's kind of weird what's
going on with these numbers so i'm not
totally sure
um
and then
lastly they're still counting ballots in
pennsylvania although not literally
literally right now i believe that they
have paused for the evening
david do you believe moderate
republicans exist romney and collins are
considered moderates but their records
suggest otherwise well they're moderate
in their rhetoric
and they're more moderate i guess
socially
i don't know it's
it's always a fraught thing because if
you name the wrong person then you get
attacked you're like that's not a
moderate you must be a radical
so it's always uh it's always kind of a
fraught thing
um other
voicemails coming in
hi david love your show um my name is
joanne i'm calling from
montreal canada and
i just want to tell you what a tragedy
that shooting
is in texas i don't know what's going on
down there in the u.s we used to think
that
americans were
some of the kindest people but
i just don't know anymore what's
happening down there
well many of us are
um
what i don't understand is
um
18 year olds are allowed to buy guns and
assault rifles right but they can't
drink
right alcohol until they're 21. normal
countries women no longer have the
choice of what to do with their bodies i
just don't understand
what's going on down there yeah take
care bye yeah i would uh i i would stay
in canada in fact i'm actually i haven't
talked about this too much yet but i'm
going to be spending uh some time in
canada
uh coming up
and a lot of um
a lot of lot of interesting things going
on
uh all right let's see
oh jen from providence called in hey
david it's jen from providence i don't
know if anybody's ever mentioned this
but do you think the reason why
republicans are never going to care
about the shootings is because they're
usually wealthier and that their kids
typically go to private schools or even
charter schools
i don't think they really care too much
about the poor public school kids
getting shot well they don't care no i
wouldn't say that jen it is true that
republicans have just many republicans
have disdain for public schooling that's
absolutely true
but i don't think they quite literally
don't care
uh
about the kids
it's complicated and disgusting i think
is the way i would put it but it's a
little more complicated than that sandy
hook right sandy hook was not poor kids
very well said
a user in twitch says david i'm a
canadian immigration lawyer definitely
options for you to become a permanent
resident in the country you guys want to
know something i don't even know whether
i should be saying this but
oh man do i even do this
i guess i do i'm going to be vague
enough about it that nobody's going to
get in trouble
okay
we all know that
different countries have different
immigration rules okay
and there are countries where it's sort
of like known it's kind of difficult to
move permanently to certain countries
i'm not going to name any countries but
we all know it we all know just like you
can't just go wherever you want it's
some countries are difficult to legally
get a permanent status
i've gotten emails from immigration
lawyers
in
four different countries okay four
different countries
and i doesn't even matter what countries
they are but the point is they said to
me listen david
there's obviously the official rules but
i'm going to be really honest with you
um because of the size of your platform
if you wanted to move to x country
permanently
i could help you do it and and you would
be able to do it because there's
mechanisms and i'm not even going to go
into the detail that they explain but
there's mechanisms where basically like
lots of countries if you're going and
bringing a business with an established
presence even if my employees wouldn't
actually be living in that country
that there's all sorts of shortcuts
which to me sound completely unfair
quite frankly what i have a youtube
channel so i can move and skip
and it's uh
it's sort of weird because
arguably if i just moved my american
business to some of these countries
um
even if okay yeah i mean i get it like i
i guess i'd pay some taxes there but
then i get to deduct those taxes in the
united states i don't know like i might
pay a little more in taxes total but
it's not like a terrible deal for me and
i and you know whatever
um
it just doesn't really seem like that's
fair you know what i mean it's sort of
the same thing where like
i get free stuff all the time from
advertisers where they want me to try
products or sometimes it's not even an
advertiser i'll just get stuff in the
mail where it's like hey
i just love what you're doing david i
want to send you you know whatever
and it's like it should really be going
to someone else like i a lot of the
stuff i don't need and it's the same
type of thing with a lot of these things
where once you get to a certain point
where you don't need a certain thing
it's made very much available to you
where there's tons of people who would
love to actually move to certain
countries with good economies and get a
job and really work there in a real way
rather than me i'd be sitting in a room
with a mic if that makes sense
um
some countries let you in if you have a
certain amount of money yeah this place
is also like portugal where if you just
essentially buy a piece of real estate
or buy a certain amount of
stocks and bonds yeah it's there's
there's a lot of crazy crazy stuff out
there
um
okay
let's see here uh oh people want to
listen to a little let's listen yeah
okay remember you're
you're the loved ones that were taken
today uh both the students and the uh
and i believe it was one teacher as well
uh we need to remember them
um
you know we heard the president come on
and say he's sick and tired of things
and i agree with him but uh
i think there's some more pragmatic
things we can do to start moving things
forward and some of them senator
blumenthal who's worked with us
previously has mentioned which is the
red flag laws um
for those who are we're going to be
talking about that quite a bit tomorrow
i'm being advised to check out chris
murphy's speech let's see
chris murphy's speech about the shooting
let's see if we can find it
here it is on the floor
of the actually let's see if we can just
play it here
fourteen kids
dead in an elementary school in texas
right now
what are we doing
what are we doing
just days after a shooter walked into a
grocery store
to gun down african-american
patrons we have another sandy hook on
our hands
yep
what are we doing
not much
there's been more mass shootings than
days in the year
200 kids are living in fear
every single time they set foot in the
classroom because i think they're going
to be next
what are we doing
why do you spend all this time running
for the united states senate
why do you go through all the hassle
of getting this job of putting yourself
in a position of authority
if your answer
is that as this slaughter increases as
our kids run for their lives we do
nothing
what are we doing
why are you here
if not
to solve
a problem as existential as this
this isn't inevitable
these kids weren't unlucky
this only happens in this country
and nowhere else
nowhere else do little kids go to school
thinking that they might be shot that
day
nowhere else do parents have to talk to
their kids as i have had to do about why
they got locked into a bathroom and told
to be quiet for five minutes just in
case a bad man entered that building
nowhere else does that happen except
here in the united states of america and
it is a choice
it is our choice
to let it
continue
what
are we doing
in sandy hook elementary school after
those kids came back into those
classrooms
they had to adopt a practice
in which there would be a safe word that
the kids would say
if they started to get thoughts in their
brain about what they saw that day
if they started to get
nightmares during the day
reliving stepping over their classmates
bodies as they tried to flee
the school in one classroom that word
was monkey
and over and over and over through the
day kids would stand up and yell monkey
and a teacher or a paraprofessional
would have to go over to that kid
take them out of the classroom talk to
them about what they had seen
work them through their issues sandy
hook will never ever be the same this
community in texas will never ever be
the same why
why are we here
if not to try to make sure that fewer
schools and fewer communities go
through what sandy hook has gone through
what yuvaldi is going through our heart
is breaking for these families
every ounce of love and thoughts and
prayers we can send
we are sending
but i'm here on this floor
to beg
to literally get down on my hands and
knees and beg my colleagues
find a path forward here
work with us
to find a way
to pass laws that make this less likely
i understand my republican colleagues
will not agree to everything that i may
support but there is a common
denominator that we can find
there is a place where we can achieve
agreement
that
may not guarantee
that america never ever again sees a
mass shooting
that may not overnight cut in half the
number of murders that happen
in america it will not solve
the problem of american
violence by itself
but by doing something
we at least
stop sending this quiet message
of endorsement
to these killers whose brains are
breaking who see the highest levels of
government doing nothing
shooting
after shooting
what are we doing
why are we here
what are we doing
all right there is senator chris murphy
speaking in the senate
uh earlier today
crazy time
crazy time
uh
steven says david do you still hold the
very incorrect opinion that granny smith
apples are the best i do
loved your very correct satsuma mandarin
coverage all right well i guess i could
do something right there
um
okay i i interrupted a voicemail earlier
let me go back to it okay
hi david i'm watching your live stream
um
about the uh
the midterms slash shooting
um
i think that lady that was just on the
anderson show had it uh pretty right
about talking about
the um
how morbid it is to have to go identify
a child because
they're the only ones to identify it
[Music]
i know this would be graphic but i think
they need to show it to the american
people
right show the graphic picture
that people wake up to see what a
a little child looks like after a bullet
rips through their head
well this is one of the things that is
different in the coverage of war
in the media and many other countries
this was a big topic during the 2003
invasion of iraq which was in the united
states
due to a combination of sensibilities
probably to some degree just kind of
like people's belief about
what people want to see
and maybe even to some degree the uh fcc
guidelines
in the u.s you got a really sanitized
version of what was happening in iraq i
mean what somewhere between a hundred
thousand and a million iraqi civilians
died
were there really graphic videos of that
shown in american news media no
no
in many other countries i can say in
europe for example where i where i have
seen coverage directly i don't know
about in argentina
i'm just not sure i just don't remember
the coverage of war is much more graphic
i would argue much more accurate
and support for many of these incursions
is significantly lower
not a shock
not a shock
um
yeah
let's check out the texas 28th data
there's a lot of people talking about it
so
politico still has cisneros ahead
um
cnn has queller ahead
and then i'm being told 270 to win okay
let's see 270 to win
let's see how this is going primary
results
let's see what's going on here
so we're looking at texas
and we're looking at the 28th
henry kweller this is with only 49 in
yeah so i don't know guys because this
data seems even more stale this was with
only 49 counted
right now
the um
panel
with the most vote counted is politico
and that's the only one that has
cisneros ahead right now so i guess we
we just don't know
okay
uh
yeah so we're gonna keep an eye on that
this is from earlier we've already seen
the joe biden speech earlier today
i want to say thank you to simon reed
for signing up for a membership and
gifting one
also big thank you to nathan thomas
for gifting a membership so that's two
gifts it does put us at 67.
those
free memberships go to
uh let me just load up my my queue
javon bukaya
and oliver payton are the recipients of
those membership gifts i really
appreciate that
uh very much
new york times still has cisneros ahead
let's take a look at that
um
[Music]
let's see if i look at texas here
uh
oh i'm like not logged in oh it's gonna
be difficult to pull up okay i apologize
i i take everybody's word for it but
we have different percentages of the
vote counted
but the vote counts or lower on politico
oh is that true
let's see so here we've got about 25 000
votes counted
here we've got about 27
and here we've got about 29. oh that's
interesting that's interesting yeah
that's a fair that that's
counterintuitive
lower percentage
but it's actually a higher number of
votes
okay
we are going to watch that
david daley co's elections usually has
the most up-to-date and accurate counts
well i mean
everybody has a different perspective as
to which they think should be used yeah
the percentage is an estimate that's
absolutely true
all right let's do a run through of the
data that we have so far so
in the alabama republican senate primary
only 20 of the vote in extremely slow
vote count katie britt is in the lead
sarah huckabee sanders has won the
gubernatorial republican primary in
arkansas
brian kemp has won the republican
primary for governor in georgia
and stacey abrams won unopposed on the
democratic side they will face each
other
in the fall
marjorie taylor green has won will
almost certainly run against marcus
flowers in november
and we are still watching a number of
other races here okay that's where we
are at this point in time
we may or may not learn more tonight
but that is going to conclude my
coverage 8 to 10
uh eastern time as scheduled tomorrow we
will cover these results
we work we'll cover the tragic texas
shooting
and the vile disgusting reactions from
so many elected officials
who are sort of taking the approach of
we can't really do anything to fix this
even though it's not happening in any
other country
for some reason there's really nothing
we can do
and we're all out of ideas even though
we've tried nothing which is
extraordinarily depressing
extraordinarily depressing
all right thanks everybody for joining
me and we will see you tomorrow
you